big news in the fight against covid19
the trump administration asking
states to speed up vaccinations for
people older than 65
by not holding back the required second
dose
health and human services secretary alex
azar says the distribution in states has
been too narrowly focused it comes as a
record number
of americans were vaccinated on monday
joining me now to discuss is dr mark
siegel professor of medicine at nyu
langone
great to see you as always mark first i
just want to know why
there would be a reason for any state to
hold back on that second dose because
you're not fully vaccinated or
immunized until you've received both
no exactly and that's been a source of
controversy good morning julie and it
really shouldn't be
because what alex azar is saying now by
the way is that there's enough vaccines
coming out
finally manufactured so that he can
pretty much guarantee that there's
enough second doses out there
for everybody to get so that's why he's
saying liberalize the guidelines
kind of give everybody the first those
and i have to say
the strict adherence to these guidelines
has been a huge part of the problem here
and i was also happy to see
azar say look everybody over the age of
65
has got to be vaccinated as soon as
possible we we have enough doses
a 1.25 million doses were given out
yesterday alone which is a huge increase
over 500 000
they're heading in the right direction
but they got to get to about 3 million
doses a day
to really start to break the back of
this yeah 1.25 million
people vaccinated on monday that's
certainly an uptick and that's a great
number to see
um you talk about the elderly so you're
talking about 65 and up i don't
necessarily think of 65 year old as
elderly but
65 and up should be first in line and
front
front line workers as well but is this
enough to stay ahead of the virus
well that if if the right people are
vaccinated let me tell you why
there's over 130 000 people hospitalized
in the united states from covid right
now
and about 80 or more of the deaths are
people over the age of 65.
so if that if we can have the met the
rubber meet the road here
and really vaccinate the elderly and the
high-risk groups
we're going to decrease dramatically on
hospitalizations and deaths
even before we get the whole population
vaccinated
so i'm really interested to see that
nursing homes 39 and 40
of the deaths we get all the nursing
homes everyone in the nursing home and
all of that workers in nursing homes
vaccinated
and then the elderly around the country
we're gonna we're gonna get there we're
gonna flatten the curve
much sooner than you might think maybe
even in march florida states like
florida are already targeting
those over 65 it's got to be a national
priority though and i believe
also we've got to see large vaccine
centers that are federally run as well
would um president-elect biden's plan to
dole out all vaccines at once help
or hurt this situation you think
well you know you started with something
that's relevant to that let me tell you
i don't think the fed should be holding
back
vaccines so i agree with with
president-elect biden on that
let's get all the vaccines out to the
states
but once they're there let's remember
that the pfizer and the modern vaccines
have both been studied for two doses we
don't know what one dose will do long
term
that hasn't been studied and we have to
stick to the science on that
we have to say the clinical trials and
the emergency use authorization
was based on the two doses at set
intervals three weeks for pfizer
four weeks from moderna we have to do
that all right i also want to touch on
this you know you know covet cases
they continue to surge across the
country california is at its worst and
nobody seems to know why
the cdc says that the number of
influenza cases however
so far this season are dramatically
lower than normal due to the
you know coveted safety measures in
place the distancing the mask wearing
and just to compare in the fall of 2019
the cdc reported
more than 65 000 cases of influenza
while this fall
there were just over a thousand cases so
if all of the preventative measures are
working then why are coveted cases still
on the rise
well this is a right time to be talking
about that because flu this is flu
season supposedly right now
and we're only seeing a thousand cases
dramatic that may mean that some of the
measures we're doing with distancing and
masking is working
but covet is much more contagious we're
not doing nearly enough there we're
traveling too much too many large
gatherings
not enough mass squaring and not enough
distancing this is a wake-up call coven
much work much more contagious
all right dr mark siegel great to see
you buddy